posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info
violente tempête d'automne a causé de
lourds dégâts
les vents ont arraché des toits déraciné
des arbres céline nous pose une question
l'arbre de sa voisine est tombé parce
qu'il ventait exceptionnellement fort il
est tombé sur un film qui a tiré sur un
poteau qui a arraché le moins électrique
sur sa maison elle est protégée par ses
assurances mais ça ne devrait pas être
sa voisine de payer la facture
on appelle un spécialiste de la
responsabilité civile et des assurances
ou alors de la voisine et donc quelles
sommes à l'aise que la cour et que
c'était assez évident bref at elle été
négligente
si oui elle devient responsable
mais l'arbre était en santé donc ce
n'est la faute de personne
c'est un cas de force majeure et c'est
donc à céline de payer heureusement les
assurances couvrent c'est dommage merci
bonne journée
posez votre question on vous trouve
l'info passer le mot
[Musique]